[Music]
something big is coming to Penghu I'll
never give up on being awesome gnarling
put them together for the Hang five the
most extreme team surfing the earth and
living the dream Wow
the hey've I've seen them surf made me
who I am today what's up little dudes
uh-oh its whoo-hoo you're the awesomest
from Sony Pictures animation and WWE
Studios JC Undertaker Hunter Paige and
mr. McMahon are putting Cody and his
friends to the ultimate test this is a
map to the most legendary surfing spot
on the flat it's a surfers graveyard to
ride the most dangerous waves on earth
you got to do more than surfing you got
a survivor she's my one big chance to
get off Pangu and make something to
myself they're taking them under their
wings
if you wipeout up here you'll be a
bucket of extra crispy oh man don't even
I'm not the food to help them overcome
their fears I can't watch this is the
moment we've been waiting for hold on
and discover the meaning of teamwork we
have each other's back no matter what
Surf's Up to wave media leg presses of
large heavy polder then on to a
one-handed handstand all while still leg
pressing the folder
[Music]
worrywart sometimes I just feel blue
krang's
shade throwers nosy so what's going on
over there and there's one thing they
have in common 100 good old do